الآن هو يخت لا مثيل له مع
عامل واحد ساعد في بنائه
ليخبرنا بأشعة الشمس في لندن ، إنها مثل
مدينة صغيرة بها أرضية رقص
مبلطة تتحول إلى حمام سباحة
ومنطقة جلوس
عملاقة بحجم فندق  اللوبي ، منطقة تناول الطعام
بها طاولة واحدة فقط تتسع لـ 20 مقعدًا.
يوجد حاملات لفائف ورق التواليت الذهبية
في
الحمامات بالخارج الآن ماريا بيبسيتش هي
رئيسة قسم التحقيق
بمؤسسة مكافحة الفساد التابعة لـ Navalny وماريا كانت تكتب
عن
هذا الأمر.  شاملة فقط حتى
الآن بشكل لا يصدق وسألاحظ بالطبع أننا
لم نتمكن من تأكيد من يملك اليخت
ولكن أخبرني بما اكتشفته في
تحقيقك ، عندما
مررت بشق الأنفس بالطاقم ومن هم
ومن أين هم  قادك إلى
استنتاج أن هذا في الواقع
هو يخت فلاديمير بوتين ،
حسنًا ، مرحبًا ، مساء الخير ،
حسنًا ، لقد كنا نحقق في
فساد بوتين لأكثر من عقد
، وإذا كانت هناك قاعدة ذهبية واحدة حول
ح.
إن أعمال الفساد التي يقوم بها بوتين هي أن
بوتين لا يحتفظ أبدًا بأصوله
تحت اسمه ، وهذا
مستحيل ، لذلك يستخدم هذه الشبكة
من أصدقائه من أصدقاء الطفولة
من أصدقاء الجامعة من kgb بعض
الأقارب وما إلى ذلك لتخزين ثروته
الهائلة وهم  تصرّف كمساهمين معيّنين ،
لذا علمنا على الفور أنه ليس من
المهم تمامًا من
يمتلك هذا اليخت فعليًا على الورق ،
يمكن لأي شخص أن يكون شخصًا عشوائيًا أو
أحد المارة ، ولا يهم حقًا
طريقة إثبات وجود طريقة واحدة
لإثبات  أن شيئًا ما ينتمي إلى بوتين
ويتم ذلك من خلال النظر في من
يدير أحد الأصول من هذا القبيل ،
لذلك حصلنا على قائمة بالطاقم ، لذلك على الأقل
قائمة بكل موظف على هذا
اليخت
وما برز على الفور هو
أه إلى حد كبير الجميع  من
القبطان كانوا من الروس ، وكان لديهم جميعًا
أرقام جوازات سفر روسية ، وكان لديهم أرقام تأشيرة
ولديهم أسماء روسية ، وكان عددهم
بضع عشرات ، لذلك
قررنا الذهاب فقط
فحصها واحدًا تلو الآخر في كل
قاعدة بيانات يمكننا الوصول إليها ولدينا
إمكانية الوصول إلى الكثير منها لأن
روسيا بلد فاسد
للغاية وقد تم تسريب العديد من قواعد البيانات ،
يمكنك شراء أي نوع من البيانات في
السوق السوداء  لذلك بدأنا للتو
في الانتقال شخصًا إلى آخر
ولا أعرف اللقب الثاني ، لقد ضربنا ،
اتضح أنه تم الإشارة إليه في
دفاتر هواتف الآخرين على أنه يعمل
لصالح أم كموظف في fso ، فهذه
وكالة حكومية عسكرية
المسؤول عن بروتوكول بوتين الشخصي لأمنه ،
فهذه هي
الوكالة التي تحافظ على مساكنه الرسمية
التي توفر
الأمن لبوتين وما إلى ذلك ، ثم بينما
كنا نواصل تدوين القائمة ، كان
هناك موظف آخر من الخصم
وآخر ثم آخر وهو
كل ما تم إضافته فقط وأعني
أن عمل هؤلاء الأشخاص هو حرفيًا
حماية فلاديمير بوتين ، هذا ما
يفعلونه هذا هو ما دفعه دافعو الضرائب مقابل ذلك.
إلى إيطاليا بانتظام
للعمل بدوام جزئي في واحدة من
أغلى مدن العالم ، لذلك لا يوجد
سوى تفسير واحد لهذا
وهو هذا